Oh hey.
Sorry. I was just busy sleeping cause
that was the most
disappointing fire ignition
I've ever seen in my life.
So,
we're gonna go and improve on it now.
And for the sake of continuity,
I've gotta wear this dopey hat again .
Apologies.
Little bit tame that last one I thought.
Yeah it's pretty boring.
How can we improve
on the previous?
Jack?
I'm thinking petrol,
fire.
You gotta step it up a notch.
Step it up a bit.
What're your suggestion Jeff?
Large amounts.
Large amounts
of everything.
I think we've learnt a
lot from this discussion.
Yeah. Let's go.
Igniting fire.
Bloody hell.
Ah.
Lovely.
That's beautiful.
Now that's what I call a close encounter.